hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome back to let's play slender haunt
oh this is now the 1.0 edition so it has
been updated as far as the gameplay goes
and also the main menu has changed there
are these pictures here that I don't
think I've found or maybe these are the
pictures I found from the last time I
played but I don't recall playing before
my whole computer exploded so I'm not
exactly sure but there are some changes
made to the game and I'm I think someone
said that there's a save mechanic so I'm
gonna try to actually beat the game here
so here we go I'm a plan on gamer
because you know he said he increased
the Slender agro and I want to get
through the game and also I want to be
able to know where I am static on the
intro is different all right so look I
got another arm what an interesting
feature
anyway I know the basic just to the
beginning and there's something called
ultra vision that he added
Oh what that that's not very ultra man
well fine
tie my flashlight back blocks good night
could I have that how about how about my
flashlight there we go
got it got it got it go all right so no
scraps left have things less noisy
nothing's going on here basically the
idea is blah blah blah blah you all know
the basic idea of the game start it out
we're gonna hit the house first check
out see if there's anything new there
whoa
now snoo okay anyway the game's looking
still just as good as ever her to hurt
her do hello what the hell we're gonna
wait out there what are you doing here
are you a really slender Polly boss ha
well you're here early
geez get away I need to get to where I
was days loop I can still change the
intensity of the flood Ayodhya
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
say what but I didn't I didn't even get
a chance
[Music]
if that's gamer I'd hate to see what
paranormalist my god okay anyway take
number two billion of God is good huh
man hey here's what I said they
increased his aggression I didn't know I
didn't know they meant that much js all
right
get that put that away get the batteries
get photo got the photo got it got it
cooking on her for dirty 40 there he was
she won t what was that now is he gonna
pop up again I hear like a staticky
thing not sure I hear thought I heard
like static coming off on the other side
there anyway I'm playing a gamer so it's
still daytime
what kind of almost nighttime right now
oh look signs green in Lookout Chapel
I'm going to the green in supposedly cuz
that's where I get the key to the
lookout tower and I just got to be
careful about slender now because
apparently he wants to fight off my
niblets ah here we go oh this looks so
nice an invite what can you hear me it's
someone in there hello is that something
okay someone said there was another page
in the house so I'm gonna go look for
that in addition to the key that I'm
gonna find like a mouse
ah they got rid of the horse doors oh no
they didn't what is this Oh found it oh
hell yeah
savegame lack of Wow okay so I'm
assuming that the picture letter is in
the top floor I'll check there first I
don't waste any time
yeah kind of subdued but it's still it's
still it's still there horse doors of
disco you behind this door can I get
around you please if I never mind then
darion okay maybe it wasn't in the top
floor I don't remember I don't remember
where I mean people said that there was
one on the sale in the house ah there it
is okay got it okay
Pollock the molle no don't come through
that door you [ __ ] holy balls
ultra vision like a glow stick how about
you go away you douche
I got turn away ha ha No
it's got a turn stair this wall this
wall is so interesting ah come on
I can't get out I can't get out he's
right I kidding
come on I'm here bro what's that
ah go get me through a door I don't
think so I'm behind a door I'm also
gonna die apparently why won't you go
away it's gonna be a bug or something
all right you're probably still ran
downstairs instead of hiding down in
this Haram hey Roger ran downstairs a
good they got saved baby I don't know I
love them just a little bit me come at
me bro running away what what the hell
are you what what happened pursue
convinces resume please thank you I
don't know what's going on here
[Music]
what ah what I'm still staticky oh no
are you pursued okay good good I was
about to say geez get out of here
dick okay and then straight out straight
out don't even bother
I'm runnin I'm a running fool run
Forrest run
batteries there wasn't anything on the
truck run Forrest run into the Forrest
Forrest run
okay see here now I'm headed towards the
lookout tower of some report and I'm
gonna I'm definitely gonna not try to
die it's my goal not die is a good goal
to have it's good to have goals you know
in life general so I need to find a
lookout tower and this flat site isn't
helping me much at the moment because it
is kind of light out and doesn't cast
that much Osama turn on my ultravision
this ultra vision is subpar at best I
mean I wouldn't even call it even a
little bit ultra I gotta find a sign I
have the feeling I'm turned around a bit
here hmm
leukemia cool waving Marat what's this
oh it's a mountain no no wrong way then
whoops group sees gypsies at least
there's better navigation around so
hopefully that'll help oh there was a
sign right there
damn me Hey look out straight out of my
come at me slender brah don't get some
I'm gonna get you and I am gonna try to
complete this game so expect a few more
visits from this at least cuz I know
this is the I mean there's a lot to this
game so I kind of want to give it a good
thorough trying it's gonna be in the
array somewhere
my ultravision turned on my flashlight
Ron haha can't get me all televisions
back Jimmy and spread up the stairs
retired Godard
Oh Joe tired this guy's good for being
able to sprint up stairs
a lot of you guys might be like hard to
you try screening upstairs you did
pretty good
it's pretty good for of out of all the
slender character asunder people in
slender games the characters say you
play he seems to be the most athletic Oh
God even more dude huh here we go save
up here - or am I just blown that if
sundar appears you know randomly on this
staircase I have a feeling I might be
boned come on don't kill me slender brah
now to the back door
I'm on I'll get it I'm on racket I'm on
a record
oh hello whoa where did that one come
back ah planets around blendings around
ah I get out here [ __ ]
no you can't Matheny he's down on the
ground that's why when I loop around the
tower he kind of pops up everyone so
long
Oh nah nah nah that's right that the
exit ah ah ah ah come on we'll be like
that yeah
where is he where is he where is he
where is he I'm just running I'm running
I'm running I'm running I got room I'm
running I'm running I'm running for it
I'll run for it you hear yo your guy
here get out here get out of here [ __ ]
fu
where's a road where's the damn road
where's the route go I don't know I
heard a flute lulla lulla lulla okay I
think this is the road to the house this
way maybe it's up that hill hopefully
nothing ah jeez just guys like really
aggressive I mean I know I slept with
your mother but no need to be rude okay
so if I had that sway away from the
Slenderman
[Music]
okay so this is another road um think
maybe this way it's hard to get my
bearings when everything looks the same
in this you know just kind of ridiculous
I mean you know don't get me wrong looks
great I love the look at this force it's
supposed to be
thunders woods or slender's forest is
supposed to be something you can get
lost in so that's a good thing it's a
kitchen that's not a house at the
mountain where am i where do I go what
am i doing I have to get back to the
house that's the only place where I know
there's a save I'm lost I'm lost I'm
lost I don't know where I'm going I'm la
fast getting back my flashlight screw
this screw the ultravision ah nah go the
other way now
sorry I just felt like running in the
complete opposite direction just got
this weird feeling you know like I
shouldn't go that way man they
definitely improved him in the new
version he is much more huh much more
problematic ooh what's this
whoo it's a sign whoo hello do not cross
poisonous plants yeah alright I'll go
let's do this no I'm not gonna go until
I get to the save point then I'll
experiment with things that could kill
me let's try not to die and then I can
die
do not across poisonous plants I have a
feeling of toads go in there at some
point oh come on where the hell am I
where am i how could I've gotten this
loss this quickly I just went in one
direction
I got I got a fine Baba what cup was
that oh that's the TV isn't it that's
the TV hello come here
I got Jeff the middle of a cornfield
that's on ya not enough time to ponder
that gotta get going
ah no not that way he keeps driving me
away from the house I think maybe baby
oh I got fine really really it's woods
thank you thank you for telling me
that's a pine tree I gotta find the way
out of here
thank you which way am I going how did I
get here where am i it's getting dark
out I'm gonna die I gotta save I gotta
save I gotta save the future of my let's
plays depends on it ah finally got a
frickin sign how did I get up there the
friggin outpost it down there how did I
get here okay wow I hear I think this
way
how did I get up there let's tell you in
fair how did I do that
Oh Oh No it's craziness I don't where
are you where are you where are you I
need to go this way I can't go any other
way but this way I gotta get back to the
house I have the frickin backdoor key
for goodness gracious sake
okay that's a hill that where's the
white balls
pow-pow running hell I don't even I'm
going in the directions I didn't Wow a
few tables willikers what is happening
to me well seriously how am i running
okay ah stop it okay I got to go down
see Oh Oh green in greenin oh thank you
finally a sign actually tell me which
way I've got to go well there's a pint
I'm not supposed to cross or the field
fret Thunder I can't run anymore please
don't kill me okay so I don't know how
it seems almost impossible that I could
have gotten turned around I have a very
good sense of direction and I don't know
what the hell happened how did I get
from the house straight to the lookout
tower then straight hand okay I'm very
very nearby I just need to go down this
way and then Wow move on move on move
and up this way
oh god I'm on the wrong way again aren't
I oh god I'm going the wrong way again
is that the house was that the house I
started just flash no item Mountain
again I'm going the wrong way I'm not
I'm not risking going to complete
let me go home I just want to go home
stop with the screen fuzz where come on
it's gotta be here it's gotta be here
where is it it's gotta be here
what the hell just happened where am I
they won right here
besides I do it right here okay all
right where where am i where am i you
dick
you gotta be
[Music]
um I'm just I'm I'm I bet I are even
how-how-how this doesn't make sense
[Music]
come on come on baby give me a sign give
me another sign
give me another sign I'm nut ah finally
turn that boss mother up yeah okay golly
gee willikers how those bulls are go
from point A to point B right back to
point a I end up going across the map up
around back down towards a house then
back up how I didn't even turn around
I'm angry it shouldn't have happened so
I'm gonna cut it here wall on angry so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for thieves and I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
[Music]